[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its hosts
and guests not those of this network the
opinions expressed are for
non-commercial informational purposes
only listeners are cautioned not to rely
on program content
to treat or prevent disease but are
advised to consult with a licensed
health care professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the superstar of alternative
health and purveyor of medical truth
dr joel wallach
hello and welcome to dead doctors don't
lie dr joel wallach your host a
veterinarian and physician
and i'm here for kids and baby boomers
and seniors who don't want to die at
75.5 like their parents and grandparents
i'm here for kids and baby boomers and
seniors who don't want to be sick and
miserable for the last 15 to 20 years of
life like their parents and grandparents
we do have lines open give us call toll
free one triple eight three seven nine
two five five two again that's toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two
well some disturbing events here um this
last friday
um florida had a big spike
in the number of infections the state of
florida 5
800 infections and then sunday two days
later
they broke the record which had been
held by the state of new york
since about a year 12 000 something
but florida went up to 15 300 on sunday
in a 24 hour period crazy and florida
has a 21 thousand
21 million 477 130
population and um right now totally they
have 2 million 346 thousand
1555 infections and 37 265
dead well let's look here at a
comparison
between vietnam and peru
kind of strange comparison but to
vietnam
97 million people has 81 dead not 8 100
not 81 000 is 81 dead
and 17 300 sections peru
okay with 32 million which is about one
third
of the population um of
vietnam has 2 million infections
and 194 387 dead
what's the difference well there's a
couple things number one there's a new
variant in peru called the lambda
which is supposed to be many times more
infectious and many more times deadly
than the delta variant
here in north america and
europe and so that's
at work here but also there's a big diet
a difference
in florida more than 50 percent of the
population
is a mix of latinos blacks and native
americans and they primarily eat
as latinos all three groups eat like
latinos
wheat brother rhinos gluten gluten
gluten and they you know
typically as a community don't
supplement
and so that's why they're having all
this bad
numbers and impact peru
east like europeans the spanish uk
the north americans a lot of wheat
around oats
whereas vietnam they stayed like
asians and eat like asians so three
times the population of peru
they only have 81 dead peru has 194
000 dead they have 17 000 infections
and peru has 2 million infections well
let's look at
and compare the usa with india where the
delta variant came from originated as
india
we have 332 million people they have 1.7
billion people they have like five times
the population we have
our debt is the worst of all the
countries in the world 622
850. the um
let's see here that people in india have
four hundred eight thousand seven
hundred ninety two
we have thirty four million seven
hundred thirty three thousand eight
hundred thirty one infections
and indy has thirty million eight
hundred seventy four thousand three
seventy six
so um but india's going up
in leaps and bounds so i suspect before
the end of this year
they will exceed us in numbers um
because our number of deaths and
i think probably um florida has more
infections than all the other 49 states
combined
okay they didn't list deaths been very
quiet about that i think everybody's
kind of shocked
but this has all to do with diet diet
diet diet gluten
consumption and not supplementing
now i want to say okay what are we going
to do about this as i said many times
after the second world war the boy
scouts the girl scouts were the locals
that actually kind of put america back
together because all the young people
were
kept in europe and asia and the pacific
to kind of hold things together after
we had won the war and so it was up to
the boy scouts the girl scouts now i
graduated
high school at 18 years of age like
everybody else but i was an eagle scout
i was an art of the arrow i had 32 merit
badges
and um i had many many skills
uh because of those 32 mirror patches
you know scouts boy scouts have 135
merit badges the girl scouts have
over 200 what they call service pins
which are the equivalent to the merit
badges and boy scouts
and so we you know had swimming merit
badge a life-saving merit badge
first aid the
communications uh let's see here we also
had cooking gardening
car mechanics pet care
farm animal husbandry and so on and so
we were
kind of trained in all this kind of
stuff we could
march and compete with any drill team
from the marines
by the time i was 18 years old because
our scout master
and assistant scoutmasters had been you
know in the military during the second
world war
and they drilled us and drilled this and
drilled us so we knew drilling
we knew small arms small weapons and so
that's why i very quickly became a
lieutenant colonel in the military
because of all my scout background well
we need to put this
together here and get all the kids
in america on kids toddy it's a liquid
supplement tastes good
and has everything in it except for the
efa so you have to have the fa's
cal toddy is extra calcium in case
they're doing physical work and sports
and cups like that
count tied with more minerals and
calcium and vitamin d3 you can sprinkles
which are vitamins and minerals there's
30 little
packets in a box called kids sprinkles i
put it on my vanilla ice cream
and my green tea ice cream and of course
the efas
and then the z-radical is the equivalent
of fucoid z
it's going to help their glams and
anti-inflammatory
thyroid and that kind of stuff let's get
these kids involved and our kids the boy
scouts and girl scouts can help save
america
back after these messages you're
listening to dead doctors don't lie on
the cbs radio network with your host
dr joel wallick if you'd like to talk to
dr wallach call between noon and one
pacific
at 831 685
toll-free 888-379-2552
[Music]
aromatherapy oils have been prized by
ancient cultures
for thousands of years youngevity's
ancient legacy true aromatherapy
is no exception essential oils are the
fragrant
life essence from plants that are gently
removed through the process
of steam distillation youngevity's
ancient legacy essential oils are of the
purest concentrations from the most
respected
and ethical distillers worldwide many
ancient legacy oils come directly from
families in the east
which have been distilling essential
oils for over 100 years
keep agent legacy's tea tree oil in your
medicine chest for first aid
tea tree oil is great for soothing the
itching and stinging
associated with insect bites burns
scrapes and other skin irritations
it's also effective as an antiseptic to
learn more about aromatherapy
and essential oils contact your local
youngevity associate today
and don't forget to ask about business
opportunities if you're the type of
person who likes to volunteer
and help others this should interest you
what better way to help people than to
help them with improved health
youngevity has been helping people
promote optimal health among
others for decades our approach to
health
is drastically different than medical
doctors
who mostly only treat symptoms as a
veterinarian
dr joel wallach discovered that many
common disease states
are actually preventable and reversible
our mission is to help people achieve
overall health and wellness and to help
educate others to achieve
optimal wellness as well and here's the
best part
while helping people with their health
and wellness you'll also be able to
build your very own
home-based business for more information
contact your local youngevity associate
and don't forget to ask about the
home-based business opportunity
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
the cbs radio network dr joel wallach
here for young giving 95 crusade we do
have lines open give us a call toll free
one triple eight three seven nine
two five five two again that's toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two
and um again i wanna go back to these
boy scouts and girl scouts
they are going to help us get the
information
to people they tend to be sponsored by
churches
service clubs and groups kind of like
the volunteer fire departments and
things like that in schools
and so you know they have a good
supervision and so forth
and um what are they going to get by
being out there and getting everybody to
get off the bad foods and take their 90
essential nutrients
what are they gonna get well they get a
monthly check which they can put into
the bank account i don't care if they're
only three years old
okay before they even old enough to be
brownies and cub scouts okay
uh they had to be co-an owner a co-owner
of their little business with their
parents or grandparents or
older brothers and sisters or cousins or
something but they can have a
an account a bank account and put their
checks in there for college by the time
they are 18 years old they have enough
money for college
also car bonus okay you tell a 10 year
old hey you can earn a car
by doing this by helping other people
they're in
okay so they're going to get something
for it
a very very good bonus and don't forget
they're going to be introducing good
health and had 25 to 50 healthy years to
all the kids
kids toddy cal toddy kids sprinkles efas
see radical uh our few crazy whichever
one you want
to to um use the capsules of pills
and then don't forget the rebound or
sports drink okay
um this is going to bring health to
america and
also bring a a kind of a satisfaction
to all of our kids because they're
helping as well as earning money for
college and earning money for their cars
okay doug what pearls wisdom you have
for us today well i've got a story here
headline going gluten-free diet here's
what to expect they say you may be
considering a gluten-free diet either
because of celiac disease or gluten
sensitivity
doing so can benefit you in health in a
number of ways
uh can promote positive weight
improvements in energy levels and boost
your nutritional
status they say you may think of
starting a gluten-free diet here are
some side effects you could expect
one study published in bmc medicine
found that going gluten-free can lead to
weight gain because many of the
gluten-free foods
are higher in vegetable fats they say it
doesn't necessarily have to mean you
gain weight though another study
published in the journal
of clinical gastrology
noted that gluten-free diet actually
helped regulate normal levels in
volunteers who are both underweight and
overweight it means gluten free may
help you normalize your weight your
lactose intolerance may improve
they say due to the intestinal damage
caused by celiac disease
as such you may find yourself having to
go dairy free as well as gluten-free but
as your intestinal damage
begins to heal from going gluten-free
you may notice that you can start
tolerating dairy products with lactose
and you may actually react strongly to
trace gluten
sensitive gluten from cross
contamination is a common side effect
nose going gluten free diet going gluten
free means eating fewer whole grains
and whole grains and bread products also
provides
a substantial amount of fiber as such
you might be getting too little fiber
and they suggest that if you do
go gluten free that you can get your
fiber from things like beans legumes
fruits
vegetables nuts and seeds say in
addition to fiber we may also miss out
on a few other key nutrients
such as the b vitamins and the which are
usually
enriched in wheat flour products at the
same time most gluten-free products
don't have this
they say some of the side effects of a
gluten-free diet are welcomed
and quite challenging to deal with when
you decide to go gluten-free
and take note that it does represent a
major lifestyle
change yeah and you can add 25 to 50
healthy years your life
save yourself an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery just ask the pope how
he's doing
you know he had half of his colon
removed but they didn't do anything for
his small intestine they didn't tell him
to get off of gluten
diverticulitis is a major side effect
of gluten consumption okay as it goes
along with celiac disease
it goes along with irritable bowel
syndrome
psoriasis eczema and all kind of stuff
and all kinds of
nutritional deficiencies even if you're
supplementing because you can't absorb
because your intestines are dead when
you eat gluten
and so it's not surprising the pope
being an italian
and everything italians eat is gluten
wheat brought around oats
even their beer is sweet by their nose
so let's give a prayer for the pope and
help save him
but let's get him on a gluten-free and
get him on the 90.
we'll be back after these messages
you're listening to
dead doctors don't lie on the cbs radio
network with your host
dr joel wallach if you'd like to talk to
dr wallach call between noon and one
pacific
at 831-685-1080 toll-free 888-379-2552
[Music]
the antioxidants found in many fruits
and vegetables are known to help
support and promote good health research
has also shown that dark chocolate
once known as the food of the gods is
rich in healthy nutrients
in fact dark chocolate is higher in
antioxidant content
than any other food youngevity has
combined a proprietary blend of velvety
rich dark chocolate
with whole fruit pulp and whole fruit
juice extracts from mangosteen
goji or wolfberry acai berry and cherry
along with vitamins and minerals
producing a smooth
rich delectable concentrate called
coconutty
it tastes so great i sometimes drink it
right out of the bottle
or pour it over ice cream coconutty is
highly bioavailable
meaning your body will absorb and make
use of all of these healthy nutrients
if you'd like to learn more about
nutritional supplementation call your
local youngevity associate
and don't forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities
hello judy de vilvis here if i could
only afford
to get one product out of everything
that product would be
the ultimate classic it has the vitamins
the minerals the bioflavonoids it even
has grape seed extract
the one product that would give you just
about everything under the sun you would
need for a perfect
nutritional program would be the
ultimate classic
by the way people that are on the go
it's very very hard
to take the liquids with them when they
go on their trip to get their
supplements in every day
well you know something you can use the
ultimate daily
tablets and the mineral capsules
when i'm going on a trip if i have
enough room i just take the two bottles
with me
if not just use a little baggie and take
a couple of daily doses with you
it's very simple it's very easy there's
no mess no fuss
no refrigeration just take your capsules
take your tablets and you're finished
for the day
to order these products call your local
youngevity distributor today
you've listened to phys if your doctor
is telling you that you can get all the
nutrients you need to stay healthy well
that's just wrong
dr joel wallick has identified 90
essential nutrients that the human body
needs to thrive
crops only need three nutrients to
thrive so where does your doctor
think the other 87 nutrients come from
they don't
so if you're not supplementing you're
starving your body
youngevity's beyond tangy tangerine will
get you a long way
down the road to getting those 90
essential nutrients
beyond tangy tangerine contains plant
derived minerals combined with vitamins
amino acids and other beneficial
nutrients
beyond tangy tangerine is a balanced and
complete
daily supplement so if you want to give
your body the nutrients it needs order
beyond tangy tangerine
today contact your local youngevity
associate to order this product and
don't forget to ask about
home-based business opportunities
we're back with dead doctors don't line
the dbs radio network dr joel wallet
care of young activity 95 crusade we do
have lines open give us a call toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two
hey charmaine you there i'm here
uh you know michigan is the state number
eleven when it comes to
uh hitting a million cases of um
the coronavirus infections okay
um you guys are and you i think you put
the nail on the head
or hit the nail on the head when you
identified why michigan
of all was um what is it
you have about what 10 million people in
the state of michigan
yep and so why why is such a small state
why are you ranked number 11
when it comes to the number of
coveted infections
because of all our micro breweries
yeah they're i think uh kalamazoo and
grand rapids
are in the top five microbreweries in
the whole united states
yeah and of course they they brew beer
and whiskey out of wheat butter and oats
rye whiskey and wheat uh is very classic
for
a beer um it's kind of interesting
australia and new zealand
they make 50 of their beer from rice and
um i think we we may have one
brewery commercial brewery that makes a
rice beer
united states when you look at china
and japan most of their beer and
alcoholic whiskeys are made from rice
and so they don't have a gluten issue
and that's why they have
fewer cases of coconut and a much lower
death rate
from covas and people with a european
background
so um you i think you hit the nail on
the head
and so what would you be your advice to
somebody who enjoys a couple of beers
on a friday night after you know a long
work work week
what would you recommend for them well
if they really care about avoiding
gluten they need to
start drinking rice beer there you go
rice beer wine
which is made from grapes and berries
that kind of stuff
and um you know kind of investigate some
of these other sources of beer that are
made from rice
again australia new zealand japan
japanese chinese and how many nutrients
should they take should they just take
vitamin c
no no no no they need all 90.
come on can't they get away with just
taking zinc for their immune system
for a while yeah
yeah i hear so many people say well i'm
taking zinc and i'm eating healthy
well as soon as they say i'm eating
healthy that means they're having
pancakes for breakfast
they're having organic organic bread
for dinner oh my gosh eating healthy is
going to kill you
okay and of course we want people to get
our
um pharmacist keith and i we came up
with a uh
cd called the red warning lights that
goes into about eight or nine different
diseases that have red warning lights
okay um and so uh for instance
um when you fall asleep a half hour
after dinner that means you have
reactive hypoglycemia you have certain
deficiencies
and you're headed towards real serious
diabetes with that
okay and so uh and so
these are the sort of things you have to
appreciate um same way
like with the pope's issues and he also
has sciatica
and they they didn't say oh this is a
very simple nutritional deficiency and
you know we're going to give the pope a
diet here a gluten-free diet we're going
to put him on some nutrients
and we'll get rid of the pope sciatica
no they're looking to do some back
surgery on him now
but thank you charmaine we'll be back
after these messages
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie on the cbs
radio network with your host dr joel
wallach if you'd like to talk to dr
wallach call between noon and 1 pacific
at 831-685-1080
toll-free 888-379
[Music]
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian dr joel wallick helped many
people on the dead doctors don't buy
talk radio program
you've also heard hundreds of people
tell how dr wallach
if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product
grab yourself youngevity's beyond tangy
tangerine
a blend of plant-derived minerals
combined with vitamins amino acids and
other beneficial nutrients
this all-natural product contains no
starch wheat
or yeast with no artificial sweeteners
or preservatives
and it's glycemic friendly each scoop of
the nutric crystals contain
equal amounts of all the nutrients it
starts out as a liquid
then is freeze dry to ensure each scoop
has the same nutrients
as the last scoop so if you want to get
your hands on a quality nutritional
supplement designed to give the body the
raw materials it needs to rebuild
youngevity's beyond tangy tangerine
is available in one pound canisters and
also
in 30 count on the go stick packs
contact your local youngevity associate
and get this great multivitamin and
mineral product
and don't forget to ask about the
home-based business opera
let's be boring and do a commercial
about cash out refinances
it's ryan and our mortgage team will
often have a listener say
i think i understand what a cash out
refinance is but can't that be bad for
you sometimes
so let's hit on that as with anything
it's certainly not the right move for
everyone
if we don't have to we don't want to add
a bunch of years onto our loan or
increase our monthly payment too much or
pay more in the long run
but because home values have skyrocketed
so far up the last few years
while rates have come so far down we've
seen many scenarios where listeners
today can pull out a significant chunk
of money from the new value in their
home while lowering the years on the
overall loan while lowering their
monthly payment and lowering how much
they ultimately pay
the key is to just look at the whole
picture and be honest with yourself
about your situation if you're looking
for someone to show you your options
we are united faith mortgage you have to
fix mortgages at the dba united mortgage
45 middle parking member new orleans
mortgage maker for all licensing
information good endless consumer access
to corporate analyst number thirteen
thirty equal housing lenders alaska
hawaii torture massachusetts
utah if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product grab
yourself youngevity's
beyond tangy tangerine a blend of
plant-derived minerals combined with
vitamins amino acids and other
beneficial nutrients
this all-natural product contains no
starch wheat
or yeast with no artificial sweeteners
or preservatives and
it's glycemic friendly each scoop of the
nutri crystals contain equal amounts of
all the nutrients it starts out as a
liquid then is freeze dry to ensure each
scoop has the same nutrients as the last
scoop so if you want to get your hands
on a quality nutritional supplement
designed to give the body the raw
materials it needs to rebuild
youngevities beyond tangy tangerine is
available
in one pound canisters and also in 30
count
on the go stick packs contact your local
youngevity associate and get this great
multivitamin and mineral product and
don't forget to ask
about the home-based business
opportunity
we're back we're dead doctors don't lie
in the cbs radio network dr joel wallet
care for young giving
95 crusade we do have lines open give us
a call toll free one triple eight three
seven nine two five five two
and a quick comparison here before we go
to callers uh we haven't talked about
brazil and um nigeria for a while
uh nigeria of course is in west africa
african nation
but they live like asians live on rice
and maize corn
beans and squash and seaweed and brazil
lives like europeans
they do a lot of that stuff with
everything you can think of
when it comes to wheat bread around oats
and let's see here the nigerians have
2 000 dead the brazilians they both have
the same population about 207
million nigeria has 2 000
dead and brazil has 530 000 dead
let's see here uh nigeria has 168 000
infections and brazil has 19 million
hello is diet diet diet
okay doug let's go to callers all right
let's head to tulsa oklahoma and
victoria you're on with dr wallach
hi victoria how can we help you i would
like to know
what you would recommend to reverse
dementia
okay please didn't get that first part i
got the dimension what was the word you
said before that
to reverse it oh to reverse dementia
okay
okay uh well there's many many different
types of dementia
okay it could be a simple vitamin
deficiency you could have
blocked arteries in the brain have
vascular dementia
you could have a cholesterol deficiency
75 of the brain weight is
made from cholesterol so people need to
get rid of the bad foods
um absolutely no fried foods no
processed meat no oils no gluten no
wheat broth right no sugar no carbonated
drinks in charmaine you're there
i'm here what would you what would you
give somebody
who has dementia to help them perhaps
make it better or even reverse it 100
percent
well first of all they got to get on the
diet no wheat barley rare oats no fried
foods no burnt animal fat no
no oils of any kind and then i would get
them on a healthy
brain and hard pack for 100 pounds of
body weight and i would add
the de-stress the synaptic of
the ultimate daily classic
and that's
that probably for the bunch of them eggs
yeah how many eggs
a lot of eggs but at least four to six
per hundred pounds of body weight
yeah there you go and they have to be
soft boiled so i'll poach soft sauce
ground
butter and rebuild the brain and shower
gave a perfect
dietary program to rebuild the brain and
the bachelor
uh the blood supply to the brain so
that's where we'd start give us a call
every couple of weeks anytime this
person goes to the doctor and gives some
kind of evaluation
and we'll kind of walk you through this
but dementia
we've had people who've been in comas
with diagnoses of
of alzheimer's disease ray mcgregor okay
in charlotte north carolina
for eight years in a nursing home being
fed through a g-tube
and sure of all things for eight years
and he'd been treated with
pharmaceuticals for three years before
he went into the coma
we gave him our program which is the
charges laid out and three days time he
wakes up and goes back to work
he didn't realize he'd been in a coma
for eight years okay doug let's go to
callers
we're just about to break time okay well
i'll go ahead and take it then
remind everybody we are looking for help
we are growing like crazy you can
imagine all this stuff going on like in
florida oh my gosh
15 000 they broke the record they beat
new york
which a year ago they had 12 000 in one
day um
so we have florida now with 15 000 in
one day
and so this is breaking here because
people you know they're not doing the
hand sanitizer they're not
doing the 90th century nutrients they're
not wearing their mask
they're not putting the colloidal silver
under their tongue to kill bugs
including viruses
you need to do all this stuff you got to
be really serious about this
and we can stop this thing but
everybody's going to have to cooperate
here
we'll be back after these messages and
that does open a line if you'd like to
talk to dr waller cults between noon and
1 pacific
at 831-685-1080
toll-free 888-379-2552 lines open
[Music]
[Applause]
hi registered pharmacist ben fuchs here
i've been studying healthy bodies for 35
years and what i've got to tell you may
shock and surprise you but if you listen
up
it may change your life diabetes or
pre-diabetes or fist glycemia bad blood
sugar
sugar storing cells have tuned out
insulin because we're pounding our
bodies with sugar and refined
carbohydrates that cells just stop
listening to insulin
the ultimate sign of insulin resistance
is elevated blood sugar that doesn't go
down when blood sugar stays elevated it
can react with various proteins in the
body especially the protein
albumin and the protein hemoglobin and
ultimately we're off to the degenerative
disease
races this is called insulin
insensitivity
or insulin resistance by the way insulin
resistance is a problem not just because
cells stop listening to insulin but
because insulin does other things
insulin is a growth hormone it makes
cells divide so even though
cells aren't listening to insulin's
command to process
sugar all the other effects of insulin
are still going on
for example even though insulin effects
on sugar processing are reduced or
diminished
insulin's effects on dividing cells
making cells divide
that's not diminished at all elevated
insulin as insulin levels go up
your cells are starting to divide really
fast that means cysts
that means growth ultimately insulin
elevations are responsible for
fibroids and cysts and gross this
ultimately means
the emperor of all maladies cancer
pharmacists been here urging you to go
to kscohealth.com to order beyond tangy
tangerine the healthy start pack and
other nutritional supplements that i
personally use and recommend you can
purchase these premium quality products
at wholesale prices online at
kscohealth.com that's kscohealth.com i'm
a pharmacist that believes that staying
healthy
and strong is not only about medicine
it's about giving your body the raw
materials it needs to do its work
go to kscohealth.com make sure you check
out the cool videos too
at ksco health.com that's ksco help
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the cbs radio network dr
joel wallet careful activity 95 crusade
we do have lines open give us a call
toll three one triple eight three seven
nine
two five five two and again people say
well how do you know all this stuff
where do i find this information well
you can go to www.drjwalik.com
www.drjwalik.com
and you can get 15 books we have over
50 dvds and over 100 cds we got
four more books coming along here and so
they cover over 600 different diseases
and so it's not like you have to
figure out what to do for each thing we
already have the recipe
okay and so you might look at that and
see which ones you might want to start
with
again www.drjwalik.com
oh and don't forget there aren't volume
discounts
and of course if you're going to do this
as a business any tools you buy
are tax deductible okay doug let's go to
callers
all right let's head to los angeles
california and marie you're on with dr
wallach
hello marie you're on the air how can we
help you
hi um how are you today fine thank you
how can we help you
i have uh high blood pressure and high
cholesterol
so what can i do about that besides take
the medicine that the doctor gives me
okay well personally i would not take
any stanton drugs lower cholesterol
because cholesterol makes up 75
of your brain weight it's 95 percent of
estrogen progesterone for women and
testosterone for men so if you go on a
cholesterol lowering drug guess what
there's gonna be nobody home there for
your sex life
all right and then of course highway
pressure is a little different story
um that can be due to many things how
much you weigh and how old are you
i'm 50 i weigh 140.
okay do you have any other issues any
higher pressure diabetes
you just say high blood pressure yeah
okay do you have any diabetes
no okay good any back problems or
arthritis joint palms your knees or back
or shoulders neck
um i have lower back pain okay do you
have gray hair
a little bit not a lot well it doesn't
matter one gray hair is the answer is
yes
okay and gray hair is not due to age
it's not an aging thing
it's due to a nutritional efficiency
it's one of those red warning lights you
learn about that without cd red red
warning lights
my pharmacist keith and myself okay
jermaine what would you do for marie
here
she has habit pressure she has a
cholesterol issue
she weighs 140 pounds and she does have
some gray hair
um well first of all she's got to get on
a gluten-free diet no wheat barley
railroads no fried foods no burnt animal
fat no oils and then
i would get her on a healthy brain and
hard pack and i would add to it the
ultimate daily classic
the msm fucoid z
vitamin d3 for absorption and as far as
the cholesterol goes
she probably doesn't really have high
cholesterol after all
i mean they lie about that yeah well
she's eating three eggs twice a day
you know not fried and not hard-boiled
but poached and softballed and soft
saucerell and butter
but uh also um and you mentioned the
things for her
back problems and so on and you'll know
that you're absorbing the nutrients
marie when your gray hair starts to go
away
you also have any uh like varicose veins
or spider veins your legs or ankles or
feet
no okay good yeah so as your gray hair
goes away you go back to your original
color whether it's black or brown or red
or blonde whatever it was
you know you're absorbing because again
that gray hair
or white hair or silver hair or whatever
you want to call it
is due to a nutritional deficiency not
due to aging
so what you have is all easily
reversible
all easily reversible so we look forward
to hearing from every couple of weeks
anytime you go to the doctor and get
some kind of status report call us and
let us know
your stories your testimony is going to
be a good thing for lots of people so
please do give us a call it's toll free
okay doug let's go to callers
all right let's stay there in california
and head over to noemi and you're on
with dr wallach
no amy you're on the air hi how can we
help you
well i'm calling to translate him for my
dad he's a spanish speaker
he's 61 years old he's six feet tall and
he weighs 178 pounds
he was hospitalized about a month ago
and they found a bunch of stuff
uh the biggest one is a biologinous
chronic leukemia
also cirrhosis of the liver he has
inflammation in his lungs
and either inflammation or over growing
of the spleen
and uh he's sweating a lot at night and
he's lost a lot a lot of weight
okay what we can give him
yeah does he have any high pressure
diabetes
no okay does he have any gray hair
yes okay he varicose veins in his legs
you know or hemorrhoids
anything like that no
okay all right charmaine what would you
do for
noyemi's friend he's 61 years old six
foot tall hundred and
you say 129 pounds 178
178 oh 178 okay can't read bone right in
here
178 okay 178
and he's got leukemia he's got liver
issues going on he's got gray hair
and um let's see here
uh he's got uh
something else here i can't rebound
writing
lungs there you go thank you lungs lungs
okay so what would you do for him
well first of all he needs to get on the
gluten-free diet too no wheat barley
ryerose no fried foods no burnt animal
fat no
oils then i would because of his weight
and everything i'd get him on two
healthy brain and heart packs
and i would add to that
the just the plain minerals he needs to
take that
and i would also add the ultimate
the cherry berry oxybody cherry berry
to give him our oxygen
okay well what about something like p
what about something like two quite z so
you can get the
yeah yep yeah yeah you could take a
three
three and then you can take msm
again for the um bone marrow
to work on that but the few coins see
i'd him take three of those three times
a day because he's got a cancer or the
bone marrow
we'll assume that's the correct
diagnosis and some of the nutrients in
the two healthy brain heart factors are
going to help his liver
and his hair color will come back
because that's just a nutritional
deficiency that's a red warning light
and the hair color will come back
because there's two bottles
of the nutrients in the healthy banana
heart pack
when you have there's one bottle for
each other being a heart package you get
two
so he could take three of those
nutrients twice a day and the hair color
will come back but that tells you that
his immune system
is rebuilding which is what you want to
be involved
in addition to the medical treatment he
may or may not choose
he does need to have his body
participate in defending himself here
from the cancer from leukemia
a lot of times it will be misdiagnosed
because when you get
a a replacement
of the bone marrow with connective
tissue and scar tissue
it can't make red blood cells can't make
platelets cannot make white blood cells
cannot make antibodies
and a lot of times doctors will call it
leukemia but it's really
just a bone marrow dysplasia okay scar
tissue because they're not getting
enough nutrition there
but you're right charmaine 100 percent
he's got to get off of gluten no wheat
powder on oats
no wheat powder on notes there cannot
be any blockage of these nutrients you
must be able to absorb all of them
and that's going to be a good thing and
so
we'll hope and pray it is kind of a
misdiagnosis he really just has
bone marrow dysplasia and not really
leukemia
but um if he does have leukemia then you
know he's got to really consider
seriously various treatment options that
the doctors give them
but the nutrition will not interfere
with any of that and so the nutrition
should be something you should be able
to do but don't give up your other
treatments
when you get on our program
we'll be back after these messages
you're listening to
dead doctors don't lie on the cbs radio
network with your host dr joel wallock
[Music]
if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product grab
yourself youngevity's
beyond tangy tangerine a blend of
plant-derived minerals combined with
vitamins amino acids and other
beneficial nutrients
this all-natural product contains no
starch wheat
or yeast with no artificial sweeteners
or preservatives
and it's glycemic friendly each scoop of
the nutric crystals contain
equal amounts of all the nutrients it
starts out as a liquid
then is freeze dry to ensure each scoop
has the same nutrients
as the last scoop so if you want to get
your hands on a quality nutritional
supplement designed to give the body the
raw materials it needs to rebuild
youngevity's beyond tangy tangerine is
available
in one pound canisters and also in 30
count on the go stick packs
contact your local youngevity associate
and get this great multivitamin and
mineral product and don't forget to ask
about the home-based business
opportunity
many believe that all life began in the
earth's oceans
we do know that the oceans and seas are
still abundant with life
and life-sustaining nutrients many
cultures
have long believed in the life-giving
properties of plants
and sea life harvested from the oceans
youngevities oceans gold is a
proprietary blend
of seaweeds algaes mosses kelp
sea cucumbers and sea minerals as well
as coenzyme q10
calcium and iron all designed to help
support healthy thyroid function
regular heartbeat normal weight mood
stabilization
and hormone levels take advantage of
life-sustaining nutrients
from the earth's oceans with
youngevities oceans gold
if you'd like to learn more about
nutritional supplementation call your
local youngevity associate and don't
forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities
you've listed if weight loss is your
goal
try youngevity slender fx keto caramel
weight management bars
and shake designed to enhance any low
carbohydrate
or low glycemic diet by supplying the
energizing
and filling protein dieters need without
unhealthy excess carbs a keto diet known
for its low carb
intake pushing the body to produce
ketones from fat used as energy
a state known as ketosis by using
fat not carbohydrates as fuel in this
metabolic state
a keto diet supports and promotes
healthy weight management
for optimal health with this system you
should be able to lose
one to two pounds each day
so what are you waiting for start
helping people today
with your own home-based
[Music]
we're business with dead doctors don't
lie on the zbs radio network dr joel
wallace here from
activity 95 crusade and doug let's go to
callers or emails
all right let's head back to oklahoma
and darlene you're on with dr wallach
hello darlene you're on the air how can
we help you
yes doc i have two questions for you
um i have a six-month-old kitten that we
took
to the vet he had a pro-lab penis and
they
tied they did some stitches and whatever
but he still seems to be having the
problem and i'm just wondering what we
should do grand
he is on a gluten-free diet okay well i
would give him the arthrodexes one scoop
for
um 20 pounds of body weight so if you
have six months old he
weighs probably what less than five
pounds
yeah so okay so i'd give him a half a
scoop of our archer decks
half a scoop of our arthrodex okay
and then the efas and then i would also
um give him uh our zera test
it's a help support male hormone
production
and i would go ahead and give him one of
those tablets you have to grind
him up and put him in his food okay
second question quickly we only have a
moment here
okay yeah i've got a gal that's 28 years
old and
they want to stretch her esophagus
because food isn't going down right or
whatever and
she had been gluten-free for four years
but she just was wondering what we could
do for her she's not on
any medications right now
okay and how and you say she's 28.
28 5 7 160 pounds
160 pounds okay char you want to start
out with taking this one she has a
trouble swallowing
and they want to uh go for her
uh esophagus do some surgery on her
esophagus
well my son and i both have trouble
taking our pills too but i think
it's what you take with them like milk
it seems to help go down
easier than juice or
so okay let's let's let's say if she's
28 years old
so um maybe she has an oxy approach to
the skull squeezing the ninth cranial
nerve
which is the um the ninth cranial nerve
we get uh you'll see here
uh the glossopharyngeal nerve which is
the
pharynx in the tongue and also the
swallowing
and so she may have obviously approached
the skull squeezing that nine strain
nerve so that's a possibility does this
gal have gray hair darlene
uh no she does not have gray hair okay
alrighty any other issues
no okay well you know char is on the
right track
and so i would go ahead at um let's see
here
she weighs uh 150 pounds
okay 150 pounds so let's say
you're going to give her the um one
healthy brain and heart pack per month
uh that's a half a dose everything twice
a day maybe no i'd give her two health
abandoned heart packs avoid the surgery
two health abandoned heart packs per
month the full dose everything twice a
day
i would also get her two bottles a month
for the msm so you could take three of
those
with each meal that's going to support
and promote managed repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
including the skull
and take some pressure off that
glycopharyngeal nerve the cranial nerve
number nine
and so you know give us uh 90 days
before she
missed that surgery because if we're
correct she can turn it around pretty
quickly here
and it'll be a great great story in the
meantime
she's got to avoid all the bad foods
that shar says
no fried foods and processed meats no
oils or glutens and then two healthy
branded heart packs per month
two bottles of msm per month and it
wouldn't hurt
also to for you know energy if she
has sort of trouble getting enough food
down her to to
have enough energy what would you have
her drink
charmaine to increase her energy the
rebound of course
works every time well there you go
rebounders first drink with a hundred
nutrients in it
75 minerals and 25 vitamins amino acids
and um at her weight 150 pounds she'd
drink two or three of those a day i just
wouldn't ever drink it after three
o'clock in the afternoon because
it will keep you up all night so it's a
very good energy drink as well as a
nutrition drink
and so um you know keep us informed what
goes on here
because i believe this is a reversible
thing and again
surgery for these kinds of things like
giving the pope
removing a third of his colon because of
diverticulitis and it's really just a
gluten issue
okay well thank you everybody really
good stuff today thank you so much for
maine super productive job as usual
thank you so much doug's who privileged
job as usual
god bless each and every one of you god
bless our troops god bless our navy
seals
god bless the american flag god bless
our national anthem
and god bless america
[Music]
wow